a huge story in the news right now the
General Petraeus scandal y'all following
that oh yeah since General Petraeus had
an affair with his biographer did you
hear this people are snapping up copies
of the book yeah yeah the book is
available in hardcover and extremely
hardcover
[Music]
no reason to act that out I apologize no
it's reported that the wife of General
Petraeus is quote beyond furious about
the affair mrs. Petraeus said I guess he
wasn't talking about Iraq when he told
me he was busy pulling out of a foreign
territory even know what that was about
interesting fact David Petraeus was
reportedly not well-liked at the CIA
where he worked yeah tip you fellas out
there don't cheat on your wife if you
work with professional spies who don't
like you it just seems like a recipe a
disaster
I'm using a phone no one uses anything I
could have flipped open a mobile phone
well maybe the guy was in Istanbul cuz
he's a spy yeah yeah well they would
have had a rotary phone Wow sorry I
don't know about Turkish phones why you
looking over here I always look to you
for Turkish phone packs what else going
on Republicans still trying to sort out
just what happened in the election
yesterday yesterday Paul Ryan said that
President Obama was reelected because of
the high turnout of urban voters urban
voters yeah then when he was asked how
he liked his coffee Ryan said no milk no
sugar just urban
[Music]
I'm exploring the space around me
between jokes for no reason Arizona this
is big news Arizona has elected the
nation's first openly bisexual
congresswoman ya parently she did very
well with swing voters in Africa
somewhat what happens no I if I even
glanced your way the directors right
Anya well I'm very good looking
[Applause]
[Music]
now the Arsenio gangs with you right in
Africa some teenagers this is amazing
created a generator that converts urine
into electricity yeah and if you think
that's insane you should see their bong
[Applause]
can't believe this story at a gas
station in Texas at a gas station in
Texas a woman purchased what she thought
was a $200 iPad that turned out to be
just a mirror yes so let that be a
lesson make sure you buy your iPad from
a reputable gas station what you want to
do it was a mirror
[Music]
I'll just trace how long did it take her
to figure out I guess it needs to charge
more yeah I'm coming in fine but
Victoria's Secret is in trouble
with Native Americans after one of their
models appeared on the runway in panties
and a war bonnet yeah
yep Victoria's Secret apologized said we
didn't think anyone would look at her
head I mean it's not quite you you go
you chew
thank you I love the UN applause after
that